- Gary wants me to put out a
ton of content for free, right?
He wants me to be super patient,
he wants me to put all the
money back into the business,
he wants me to spend
tons of time and hours
figuring shit out that's actually current,
which takes away from leisure time.
Basically, I want you to eat
shit for the next decade.
(audience laughter and applause)
♫ Don't know if I really
need that right now
♫ I got some place to be at right now
♫ All the people who were leaving me out
♫ Now the people in meetings
I'm meeting right now
♫ Sleep on me now
♫ Pope you been dope but
don't preach to me now
♫ I got some friends who
don't speak to me now
- Got stuff done on the plane,
and Babbit had last row,
so I've been standing
out here for 10 minutes.
♫ You gotta, you gotta,
you gotta let me know
Sure, brother.
- Thank you very much.
- My pleasure. How are you?
- Good, how are you?
- Good man, what's your name?
- Ben.
- Ben, nice to meet you, man.
- Have a good day.
- My pleasure. Thank you Ben.
- Love watching your content
and everything. Keep it up.
- Thank you, brother. Thank you, brother.
Hey Mommy, how are you?
All good stuff, how was
your New Year and all that?
What are you doing now, Ma?
Okay.
Alright, I gotta go.
I love you, Mom.
(blows kisses)
Love you, bye.
We're gonna play "I like
it, I don't like it."
Here we go, I don't like it.
I don't like it.
I like it.
I love, I love this.
I don't like it.
I love it.
I like it.
I don't like it.
I don't - oh, you ready?
Hi!
(easy listening music)
How are you?
Good to see you again.
- [Woman] Good to see you too!
- Hello, good to see you.
(laughs)
Hey guys.
- Hi.
- How are you?
- [Cameraman] You should be over here.
- Yeah, I mean I'm...
- And this like the white lobby,
the shadows are really bad.
- I'm fine right here.
I'll do it right here.
Hey, guys it's Gary Vaynerchuk
and I'm super fired up
to present Business Squared
all throughout Australia,
one-day sessions where we go super deep
on how to do business in the 2020 world.
It's nice to not have DRock around.
I'm kidding, Drock, we love you so much.
But, you're getting
way too much credit for
my man Babbit's work.
Just kidding, I'm kidding again.
I'm kidding again.
Can you put a double kidding there?
Love you, DRock, we miss you.
But here is the important thing,
here is the important question.
Babbit, do you miss DRock?
- I mean, he's an alright guy.
- [Gary] You have a real
love/hate with him, right?
- We have a very love/hate...
- [Gary] A real rivalry, right?
These two characters right here,
the audio, am I micced?
Felt like Tsunami to be in
the mix, look at these angles.
Kneecaps, talk kneecaps.
- [Babbit] I mean...
- [Gary] Just kidding.
(laughs)
No, but he's the best, right?
- He's cool. He's the best.
It's actually good, because
it constantly makes me
want to work harder.
- [Gary] It motivates you.
That's gonna be a good episode.
Dropped episode 293,
reading comments here.
Somebody said, "Gary I don't
want to be an entrepreneur,
I want to grow in corporate America.
What's your advice?"
Balance, right?
Two balance issues if you
work in an organization,
most of you conform to
what you know your company
wants to hear, you say
so that you get promoted
and advanced.
This is absolutely right,
and unbelievably wrong.
Too many people just yes
their bosses to death.
Yeah, banner ads.
Yeah, television.
Because they just want
to grow and they don't
want to rock the boat.
Yet, when everybody wakes up in six years
and realizes it's mobile first video,
all the people that
were yes-ing and yes-ing
are gonna get fired for
saying the wrong thing.
So you have to find the right balance.
Playing the internal game of understanding
what the organization
likes and doesn't like
while still being historically correct
if you don't believe in it.
You have to find respectful opportunities
to tell the organization
"Hey, I don't believe that
we should only be doing direct mail.
I do think Facebook ads matter.
Hey, I think we have
more work-life balance,
or we need more hustle."
You know, it depends on your org,
but if there's anything
the org believes in
that you don't believe in,
you have to find the right, classic, kind,
politically correct, consumable way,
don't communicate the way I communicate.
(expletive)
Your way, that's natural to you,
if you want to win in a
box of an organization.
The balance of knowing what it wants.
They love to make you say something,
and then say "why didn't
you say anything about it?"
and then they kill you for it,
and so find that balance,
that is the winning formula
in an organization.
I'm about to go on this stage
in Utah, Salt Lake City,
gonna rip their faces
off, as I like to say.
And I know it sounds
aggressive, but it's really
truth and want for them to succeed.
Honestly, a lot of you talk
about like I shoot it straight,
this that and the other thing,
I think people get it mixed up,
it's not that I want to be cool, or Jersey
or I shoot it straight.
It's that I'm so desperate
for everybody to win,
because when other people win
it doesn't come at my expense,
so if people could just
feel what I feel every day,
even a tenth of it,
I would feel so great,
especially cause it impacts my legacy,
it means you're talking
about me in a nice way
behind my back, it's
just all fucking good,
it's good on good on good.
And the reality is, people that sell bad,
and they're negative,
they're loud and charismatic normally.
I'm just a good soldier
that's loud and charismatic
and that's why I rip people's faces off.
That's why I suffocate bullshit,
that's why I want you to win.
(loud applause)
The one thing that combines
every person in this room
the one thing that we
are all aligned with,
the one thing that everybody
on Youtube right there
is watching right now is aligned with,
is that everybody here
has to find the attention
before they tell me
how great their product
and service is.
What can I focus on, what
can bring the most value
to the thousands instead
of the specific needs
that everybody wants.
And the one thing for me
that I'm really focused on
these days is fear and excuses.
Right?
If you're gonna follow
the things I believe in,
you have to close your eyes
for the next five to ten years,
and not give a fuck about
anything that happened.
You have to basically take a step back,
and say "okay, Gary wants me
to put out a ton of content
for free, he wants me to be super patient,
he wants me to put all the
money back into the business,
he wants me to spend
tons of time and hours
figuring shit out that's actually current,
which takes away from leisure time,
basically I want you to eat
shit for the next decade.
(laughter)
Aren't people in here tired
of doing the same dumb shit
over and over in some
slight different variation
with some fucking charismatic
person at the top?
And not having it fucking work?
Aren't you fucking tired?
(loud cheers)
How about eating shit instead?
(laughter)
Thank you.
(loud applause)
I saw it, I saw it.
(loud chatter)
We are making excuses,
and we do it every day
cause it feels a lot better
to shit on somebody else
than look at yourself
and shit on yourself.
I don't look at anybody
else, I have no fucking idea
what you guys are up to, and
I shit on myself every day.
I critique everything I do,
everything is my fault,
period, end of story.
If somebody hits me with
a fucking car tomorrow,
I'm like "fuck, I shouldn't
have left the house that early."
(laughter)
You get into that fucking mindset,
and I promise you shit changes.
Hello.
(loud cheers and applause)
Thank you.
You need to fucking
suffocate your bullshit.
You're at this conference,
that means you need to
suffocate your bullshit.
Period.
You either need to figure
out who's holding you back,
and their judgment and go to them.
I want you to get out of
this fucking conference,
go to your car and call
your Mom and say fuck you.
(laughter)
If she's the person
that is suppressing you,
because she's miserable
and misery loves company,
I'm being dead serious with you.
- I can't even.
There's no words.
(laughter)
No words. Gary is like, the best, ever.
I can die a happy death now
because I saw Gary Vaynerchuk.
(laughter)
- Now, everybody's favorite
part of every daily beat:
airport Gary.
I'm a little bit worried right now.
Yeah.
Regret scares the shit out of me.
Regret is the fuel besides gratitude
that drives my life.
You will see people and
they will tell you things
about the things they didn't do,
and the silliness to
why they didn't do it,
and they're running out of time.
You sitting in this
room and you have time.
You have time if you're 70, 80, 90,
you have time if you're 15.
You have time.
But to sit and list all
the reasons you can't
is just, here's how I look at it:
if anybody that looks
like you has ever done it,
then you can too.
Just landed back in New York,
you know that normal every day
road trip to Salt Lake City and back.
That Salt Lake City commute.
Anyway, feel phenomenal,
just engaged with a ton of
you on Instagram and Snap.
Feeling invigorated by the fucking game.
When you love it, it's hard to be lazy.
(smooth music)
You know, others know like,
and here's the fucking plan,
there's no (gibberish)
Fuck that!
(laughter)